no había despegado El avión de la
presidenta taiwanesa shine y ya tronaba
la tormenta china prometía represalias
taipei aclaraba que ninguna presión la
aislará del mundo y Washington acusaba
Pekín de sobreexcitaba es seguro que los
truenos se acentuarán tras la previsible
reunión de Chai con el presidente de la
cámara de representantes Kevin mccarthy
la finalidad oficial del viaje Se
estrechar los lazos con Belice y
Guatemala dos de los escasos aliados que
conserva Taiwán la finalidad oficiosa y
más relevante es estrecharlas con
Estados Unidos a pesar de la teórica
ausencia de relaciones diplomáticas la
casuísticas resuelve esa contradicción
haciendo pasar las visitas de Chai
Estados Unidos como simples paradas de
transición o escalas técnicas pasará por
Nueva York al principio de su viaje y
por los Ángeles al final la reunión con
mccarthy ni confirmada ni desmentida
será en California china ha dicho que si
se produce será otra provocación a su
soberanía y ha avanzado que tomará
represalias sobre el trampantojo del
tránsito
ha recordado que Chai no esperarán el
aeropuerto ni en el hotel sino que
aprovechará para reunirse con
funcionarios estadounidenses Washington
ha respondido que esas reuniones son
habituales así que ha pedido a Pekín que
no utilice el viaje como excusa para
emprender acciones agresivas contra
Taiwán la última vez que se reunió con
un presidente de la cámara
representantes Nancy pelosi china
reaccionó con las mayores maniobras
militares que se han visto en décadas en
el estrecho